my name is fracaso i'm a senior
investigator with environmental crime
investigations in south african national
box tell me what's the first thing you
look for when you arrive on a scene like
this well it seemed like this for a
start ideal is it must be a fairly fresh
scene where you can find not only
ballistics but any evidence that the
suspect might have left behind but for a
start you secure the scene and then look
for whatever evidence one can find they
quite often leave behind a water bottle
sometimes a knife brogues breaks and you
can retrieve DNA you can achieve
fingerprints from whatever that if they
what we did here today was basically to
do for ballistics a bullet or a spin
cartridge and we were successful we
found a bullet and you all come I notice
arms is that because of a worry of
possibly being attacked people still
being in the area well the possibility
is there but it's mainly because you are
in a game park and there are animals
here that would like to make breakfast
of you so one need protection against
dangerous animals and then also the
possibility of suspects though maybe on
the scene or in the vicinity the
poachers are clearly quite well
organized is there a sophistication to
it what is the modus operandi that
you've noticed they are quite well
organized sophistication in the sense of
they do have quite good Bush kills one
don't really find that they use
specialized equipment like Mike vision
equipment and binoculars quite good Bush
killed knowledge of the area that they
were working in and then also the way
that they work like normally would use
the cover of darkness to into the park
walking as deep as they can and then
exit again and it's night which makes it
very difficult for the Rangers to track
these people who will start because you
cannot physically visually track at
night